hi I'm Janice Fisher in IBM cloud and
I'm here to talk about for a few minutes
about security and compliance cloud
computing is driving the global digital
economy and really impacting every
aspect of our clients business and many
talk about the fact that we're in
Chapter two but what does that mean well
first the easy part
the first 20% has already moved to click
cloud and the difficult part the 80% is
ahead of us the second thing that really
means is that we've long been talking
about public cloud but the fact is the
future with chapter 2 is around hybrid
cloud customer workloads at the
enterprise class level will remain some
in private cloud some in public cloud
and some and legacy systems and that's
because that's just the right thing for
the enterprise when you focus in on
regulated industries about 40% the
analysts tell us we'll move to the
public cloud so not everything will go
there regardless of how much you are
moving to the public cloud there's two
things you need one providers who
understand this hybrid world and don't
expect you to be in a very singular
environment and the second is you need
to expect cutting-edge security and
compliance to support this era iBM is a
long-standing history as a trusted and
secure provider but we do find that the
industry in general doesn't have the
awareness of the fact that our
commitment to compliance and security
extends far into our private and public
cloud offerings we have and are
investing heavily to bring security and
clients right through to the cutting
edge offerings that we have so what does
that mean 1 we are secure evidence we
have invested in data your crown jewels
as the trusted partner to really protect
that full lifecycle of data on the cloud
it also extends the fact that our
legendary mainframe security has become
available through our cloud so that's
first we are secure second we are
compliant we have the security privacy
and compliance programs to address your
needs around the world whether its
international capabilities such as ISO
or Sauk regional such as GDP are in
Europe or FedRAMP in the United State
or industry-specific processing credit
card data or dealing with highly
sensitive data and healthcare and
financial services 3 we have the unique
combination that hybrid cloud requires
we have deep technical capabilities with
an IBM recently strengthened by our
acquisition of Red Hat who broadens our
open capabilities really as industry
recognized leaders who help with this
pivot between public and private cloud
we have industry insights that our
clients have leveraged for decades and
we have the compliance experts and
offerings who really can help you
deliver whether it's a global regional
or industry requirement so I have one
simple message IBM cloud delivers for
thousands of customers and dozens of
industry or purpose-built with controls
for sensitive data at the edge right
through to the cloud we help customers
with their compliance and regulatory
obligations and we have what you need to
be the trusted partner on your digital
transformation listen thanks for taking
this time with me today do you have
questions drop us a line below do you
want to see more videos like this in the
future be sure to LIKE and subscribe and
don't forget you can always get started
in the cloud at no cost by signing up
for a free buy BM cloud account